writing software is hard
writing good software is even harder it
requires focus discipline and a great
deal of perseverance
but with the right mindset the process
becomes a whole lot more manageable
if you've been writing code for some
time you know that almost all of the
technical difficulties you have faced
weren't the technical concepts but the
challenge of maintaining the right
mindset
in recent years mindset has been a
highly researched area of psychology led
by the stanford psychologist carol dweck
in her work she defined the fix and
growth mindsets as follows
in a fixed mindset students believe
their basic abilities their intelligence
or talents are just fixed traits
in a growth mindset people believe that
their most basic abilities can be
developed through dedication and hard
work brains and talent are just the
starting point this view creates a love
of learning and a resilience that is
essential for great accomplishment
when professor carol zwack analyzed
students mindsets she did not identify a
purely binary result
though most students in the classroom
lean strongly toward one side or the
other most were found to have mindsets
somewhere in the middle
they might believe for example that
their ability to improve at math comes
down to learning strategies and their
own attention and commitment to the
learning process but they might also
believe that their reading and writing
abilities are inherent
dweck also noticed that many seem to
believe that it all comes down to effort
she noted that even some teachers seem
to believe that they could improve a
student's achievement by telling them to
try harder she called this a false
growth mindset don't get me wrong effort
is important but more crucial is a
student's attitude toward learning a new
thing and their perspective on failure
as a part of the learning process in
essence students with the growth mindset
understood that positive improvement was
possible
they believe that to achieve their goals
they must view failure as a part of
learning put in the time embrace the
challenge and develop new strategies to
overcome each challenge working toward a
goal without these views is unlikely to
elicit positive results
in other words cultivating a growth
mindset won't do much without putting in
the necessary time and practice to
develop a new skill
now that we've discussed the
fundamentals of growth mindset let's
walk through some tips on how you can
develop one
first determine where you sit now do you
consider yourself more or less in the
growth mindset pool and you're looking
to make sure you stay that way
or would you describe yourself as having
a fixed mindset knowing where you stand
to begin with is the first step you
can't tell where to go if you don't know
where you are second explore why you
want to develop a growth mindset
what is it about the growth mindset that
motivates you to change and what
benefits do you see a growth mindset
bringing to your life
understanding this will give you purpose
during the difficult stages of
developing this worldview
third find examples of others who have
developed a growth mindset
start talking to your friends family and
colleagues about the growth mindset see
if anyone you know has also been working
on developing one they might be able to
provide some valuable insights
fourth change your perspective on
failure start viewing failure not as a
sign of inability but as part of the
process of learning
you can either succeed or fail but you
will always earn more than you lost if
things go how you expected you got what
you wanted if they don't you learn a
precious lesson
failure is here to let you understand
what you are doing wrong how you can
improve and what you can do better
finally understand your own limitations
recognize that some things will be
beyond what you can achieve
this helps you to set realistic goals
also notice how you talk about talent
and skill
you find yourself saying things like i'm
no good at this or she's just naturally
talented
swap those phrases out for i'm not great
at this yet and she's clearly put a lot
of effort to become so talented
notice how others around you speak and
act and then seek out those who have
growth mindsets and foster your
relationships with them
we all know that life will always find a
way to throw something difficult at you
try not to see these challenges as
obstacles or setbacks that you dread
rather try to view them more positively
try to view them as opportunities to
overcome something difficult and grow as
a result the more difficult the
challenge the greater the opportunity
for learning and growth cultivating a
growth mindset is not an easy task nor a
painless process it requires constant
setbacks and practice as well as being
open to failure and receptive to
criticism
it's not the easy road to take but is
the most fulfilling
once you're far enough along on the path
of growth mindset looking back on how
much you've accomplished is a delightful
reward
while the path might look like
individual accomplishments in hindsight
each successive growth point is
supported by a solid foundation of right
choices as momentum is built each
decision point becomes increasingly
effortless
the more effortlessly we can flow
through episodes of doubt the greater
our accomplishments can be if you found
this video useful i'd appreciate it if
you smash the like button and click on
the notification bell
also make sure to subscribe to the
coding tech channel for more videos like
this in the future